hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
minimum window substring we're given two
strings
s and t and we want to return the
minimum
window in the string s which contains
every single character present in
string t and it's possible that that
might not even exist
in which case we can return an empty
string
so in this case our string s is this big
long string
and our string t is this a b
and c so we just need we don't need to
find
a b c in here we just need to find
a substring of s that contains
all these characters and we want to find
the minimum string that contains all
these characters
so one possible string is
this right it has a d o b
e c so it has a b and c
but there happens to be a shorter string
that has
all of those as well this string b a
and c so they are out of order so b
a c and there's an n in there as well
but this happens to be the shortest one
it's length four and so that's the
result that we're going to output
so what's even a brute force way to
solve this so we're given
s and t right and we want like if we're
checking
a substring right like this substring
maybe this is our solution right
how do we even determine that well let's
use some hash maps
so these two are our hash maps you can
see i have one for t
what does this hash map represent well
you look at t right
because for each of these substrings we
just want to make sure
that it has at least one a right
one a has at least one b
and it has at least one c because that's
what we have over here we just want to
make sure
that we find the minimum substring in
s that satisfies this condition
so for every possible window that we
check in s like maybe we check
this window we are gonna want to have a
hash map for the window and we're gonna
count how many a's do we have initially
we're gonna start with zero right
because
because initially our window is gonna be
just empty or whatever
we're gonna start with zero b's and zero
c's but for this
current window you can see we have one a
one b and one c right so
we have one a one b and one c so
as we compare right we compare how many
a's do we have versus how many do we
need right this is how many we need and
this is how many we have in our current
window
you can see we need one and we have one
right
so the relationship we're looking for is
greater than or equal right we want the
counts
all to be greater than or equal but one
thing you can see is brute forcing
is gonna be difficult right so let's say
we initially start with
this window right we see we just added
an a so what are we gonna do we're gonna
update this now let's just check is our
window valid
well we have at least one a and so
remembering that this is how many we
have in our current window and this is
how many we need to satisfy the
condition
so initially let's start with this
window just
one a so then we can update our count
for this window right add
a single a so now my question is have we
satisfied the condition do we have
everything we need
well how are we going to check that well
we have to check
all of these right so is the have count
greater than or equal to the need yes it
is what about
this is the beat count uh greater than
or equal to
how many we need the answer is no right
so therefore we don't have how many we
need
so therefore we have to actually expand
our window right we have to add another
character
this d right but that's not actually
going to update
our window because we don't need any
characters other than a b
or c so we don't really care about the d
the same thing is true for the o
but now we have a b right that's good
because we do need a b
so we add a b so now we're gonna have to
run the same operation do we have
everything that we need so we're gonna
be doing some repeated work do you
notice this repeated work we're doing
we have to check if we have enough a's
which we know we do because we already
checked that when we first added this
element so we notice we do have enough
a's
do we have enough b's well this time we
actually do because we just added a new
b
right that's the most recent character
we added great so we know we have enough
b's
do we have enough c's we do not have any
c's
in our string the count is zero
therefore this condition is not
met so we do not have our result yet we
have an a and we have a b
but we need to add more so now we're
gonna add an
e which we don't really care about we're
gonna add a c
so finally we have so finally we can see
that we met
our condition right but we with our
current algorithm our brute force way we
have to repeatedly check
every one of these even if we already
know the count is
met so this is basically where our
repeated work this is what i'm going to
show you how to eliminate but
as you can see we have enough a's we
have enough
b's we have enough c's so therefore this
is a
possible result it might not be the
minimum but it's a possible result and
what's the length of this
it is 6. so we can say for now
that our result is length 6 and it goes
from index
0 all the way to index five
so i'll put zero five that's our current
result
so one thing we noticed is we're having
to do a lot of repeated work
to check that we have everything that we
need we have to check
every single one of these characters
right
but we don't we know we don't always
have to do that so let me show you how
to do it without repeating all of that
work
we're going to start out the same way so
we're going to add an a right that's our
first character
so now we're going to check so now what
we're going to say is a count
is 1 right so now my question is do we
have to check
every single one of the halves because
initially we
know that none of the conditions have
been met right
initially we start with all zeros we
also
know that the number of characters that
we need
is gonna be three right meaning
we need to satisfy the count condition
for three
unique characters right and we know that
we
start out with a have value of zero
because we know for each of those three
characters
we have met the condition for none of
them right initially we met the
condition for none of them because we
start out with all
zeros but now you can see we just added
an
a so let's check just for this one
character
have we met the condition is the count
greater than or equal
than one yes it is we have one and we
only
needed one so we met the condition so
what does that mean
we can take our have value and update it
so initially it was zero
now we can change it to one so now we
have one but my question
now is have we met the condition well we
need three but we only have one so we
haven't met the condition
you can see what i'm doing here right
before we needed to check the condition
for
all three of these each time now we only
have to check the condition
for one we have one value that tells us
how many we have
we have one value that tells us how many
we need so before we were
we had to continue running an operation
of length
t which is in this case 3 but who knows
it could have been bigger
t could have been 10 it could have been
100 it could have been anything
and we would be bounded by that but in
this case we only have to do
one operation for comparing these
integers
and one operation for comparing the
integers of the character
that we just added so for each character
that we add
we only have to do an o of one operation
so now let's add another character let's
add the d we know that doesn't really do
anything
we add the o that doesn't do anything we
add a b this is good so
how am i going to do things differently
this time well like usual
i'm going to change this one this zero
to a one we know we have
one b so now i'm going to check has this
condition
been met or is it equal
i know last time i showed you greater
than or equal but really what we're
looking for is
are they exactly equal because that's
when we know the condition has been met
so if these are exactly equal which they
are in this case one equals one so what
that means
is we can increment our have value by
one before it was it was one now we're
going to actually change it
to two and now let's check are these
equal now have we me do we have what we
need
it's not because two is less than three
so we haven't met the condition yet so
we have to continue but notice how that
was an
o of one operation we just had to make
one comparison here
and then one comparison here we didn't
have to go through the entire list
so now we're gonna add an e which we
don't really care about
now we're going to add a c which we do
care about so let's update the length
of this now are these exactly equal
we know we just met the condition for
these last two
now have we finally met our last
condition
and yes they're both one so we can take
this
through this two and replace it it's
getting a little messy
but i hope you can see it so we have a
three here so now let's make the
comparison
between these two and yes they are
exactly equal so what that tells us
is this string contains we have exactly
what we need
right so we met the condition this is a
possible result
and i'm just going to take the two
indices the start and
the ending of it which is 0 and 5 and
i'm going to put that as our current
result
so our current result is from 0 to 5.
and the length of that result happens to
be
six right so now what are we gonna do
are we just gonna keep adding elements
again and again
well we wanna find the minimum so let's
at least try to find
a string that's less than six so what
are we gonna do let's
remove the leftmost character and
keep doing that until this condition is
no longer valid until we
don't have what we need anymore so we
can try to at least find
a smaller result because ultimately
we're looking for the minimum string
so i'm going to take this character and
remove it from
our current window and so we're removing
an
a so what that means is we have to
update this
so it's no longer one we actually have a
zero for count
a now and now we know that this
condition
is this is less than what we need it to
be so this condition is no longer valid
so
that also means we have to update this
value
so before we had a three but now we have
to put a two we only have
two of these conditions matt write these
two characters b
and c so now we're actually just going
to keep adding characters we're going to
keep
looking for the minimum so we add an o
but we know we don't care about that we
add a d
we don't really care about that we add
an e we don't care about that
we add a b over here right we do care
about b
so what are we gonna do we're gonna take
the b count
it's one currently now we have two
now that's great because we actually
have more than what we need right we
we need one but we have two so am i
gonna take this
and update it no because they're not
equal
what that means is we added an
unnecessary character it's okay
but it didn't help satisfy the condition
we already know
this and this were satisfied this is the
one that needed to be satisfied
so since it's not exactly equal we're
not going to
increment our have count so now let's
add another character
the a that we wanted so badly so
we added an a we update the count of a
we add one
so now this is one we're gonna check are
they
exactly equal have we met the condition
now
by adding a character did we make these
exactly equal
and we did so what does that mean well
we met one more condition
so we update our have count it's now
going to be set
to three and now these are actually
equal
so we actually met the we have exactly
what we need so we potentially
found a result now the only problem is
this
result goes from index 1 all the way to
roughly
index 10 so it's actually bigger than
our current result which
is a problem so we don't update our
result yet
but now we want to try to find an even
smaller substring than this so let's
start popping characters from the left
so we pop a d
but d's we don't care about so we don't
update our window
and let's just keep popping values until
this condition is no longer met so
now let's pop a b so let's
now we have to update our value of b so
this was originally two now it's going
to be set to one
so now it's set to one so did we or
did we undo this condition is this
condition no longer valid nope
because this is still greater than or
equal to the count that we needed
so the condition is still valid we don't
have to update our have count yet
so actually this string is
still a possible result but notice
this string goes from index 4 all the
way to index 10 so it's actually
length 7 and that's still greater than
this string so we cannot count this as a
result yet so now we remove
the e and then we remove the c
so we have to actually update our count
again so this was originally
one now it's going to be zero
and now you can see that this condition
is actually no longer valid
so even though these two are still valid
this one is not valid we have to update
our have count
so our have count was three but now we
removed one so it's going to be
two so now it's no longer equal so our
string is no longer valid
it's length five but it doesn't have
a c we have a b we have an a but we
don't have a c
so we can't update our result so let's
keep
adding characters now maybe we'll find
another valid string so we add an
n but we don't care about ends we add
the c
that we want so we added a c so we
update our c
count now it's set to one these are once
again
equal so since they're exactly equal
that means we
just now have met the condition so we
met one more condition
so we can update our have count now to
three that means it's exactly equal to
what it needs to be
that means this is a valid string so
this goes
this goes from index 6 all the way to
index 12
that's a length of 7 which is not
smaller than our current result
but that doesn't mean we can't shrink
this right so let's
start from the left and keep popping and
making it smaller
but also keep going until it's no longer
valid anymore
so we pop in oh let's remove a
d but we're still valid right we didn't
update any of these
and now you see we have a string of
length
five so we can actually update our
result
so now we're going from index 8 to index
and that leaves us with a length of 5
but we're not done yet we have an e we
can remove that
e as well now you notice we're still
valid we have a b
we have an a and we have a c
we didn't have to update our map our
have count is exactly equal to the need
so now we can update our result one more
time
and it's gonna go from index nine all
the way to index
twelve that's the string the length of
it
is four and lastly we are going to
remove
this b character from it as well and
once we remove the b
you can see okay we removed this one now
we have zero b's remaining
uh that's less than how many we need so
we have to update the have count so we
set it to
2 the condition is no longer valid
and so are we going to continue our
algorithm well we have no more
characters
left to add we reach the end of the
string so
since this is our current minimum and
our current result this is what we're
going to end up returning
and by the way we just solved this
problem
in big o of n time because you see we
added each character
once that's an o of one we removed each
character once
every time we added or removed a
character we did at most
two operations right we had to update
one spot in our map and we had to
potentially update
this right okay so now let's finally get
into the code the first thing i'm going
to do
is actually handle a edge case so if
the input string t which is you know our
string is like the substring that we're
looking for if it's empty then what i'm
going to do
is return an empty string because that's
just how they want us to handle it in
this problem
and i'm going to have two windows that i
showed previously so
count of t and just the current window
that we have they're both initially
going to be hash maps they're both
initially going to be empty
and the first thing i want to do is
initialize
our count t map because we know this map
actually isn't going to change at all
so for every character in string t i'm
going to
add one to it but the
value i'm going to get i can't just do
this because it's possible that
c hasn't even been added to count t yet
so i'm going to do some python stuff
i'm going to use the function get which
is good for this so i'm going to get c
i'm going to get the count of c so if c
exists
in our map it will give me the value
that's stored in here
if it doesn't exist i can put a default
value which is going gonna be
zero so if it doesn't exist this
function will return
zero so that's just a way that i like to
handle
this case so now that we've initialized
the count of t
we can have our variables have and
need so we know have initially is going
to be
zero because we have zero of the
characters we need and
need is going to be initialized to the
length of
count t because that length of count t
gives us the unique
characters in the string t and then i'm
just going to start
iterating through every character in
s so i'm going to use a right pointer
for that the r is going to tell us the
right boundary of our current
window so i'm going to get the character
that we just
reached which is s at index r so i'm
just going to put it in a variable c
so with c we know we can update our
current window so i'm going to do
window of c and add one to it
for the character that we just reached
and here i'm basically doing what i did
above if c has never been added to
window we're just gonna
return zero with this function so 1 plus
0 we'll put a 1 here
if it does already exist this function
will get us the count that was
stored in here so we're updating our
window we're adding the count to it
now we want to know does this count
completely satisfy what we were looking
for does
window of c equal exactly
count of t that means we just satisfied
a condition for the first time
but one thing i also want to check
before i check this
is that c is even a character in count
d count t so if c is in
count t and this is true because we know
we don't actually care about the
characters that aren't even
in the string t to begin with and we
know if this is true we can
update our have count so we can
increment it by one
this means we just satisfied a condition
so now what we want to know does
have equal need exactly so are they
actually
equal if that's true i'm going to run a
loop and i'm going to show you why it
needs to be a loop
so we actually met the condition let's
one
update our result potentially right so
if we found a new minimum result let's
update so this actually reminds me that
i didn't even set a result so let's set
our result
and our result length so initially we
know our result is going to be a pointer
like a left and right pointer so i'm
just going to give it a default value of
negative 1 negative 1.
and for the result length i'm going to
put float infinity
because that's a good default value in
this case because we are looking for the
minimum string so any value will
obviously be less than infinity
and i'm also going to initialize a left
pointer
because we know r tells us the right
pointer left pointer will initially be
set to zero
but so now we can actually update our
result we know the condition has been
met
so if the current length of our string
which is going to be
r minus left plus 1 this is how you just
calculate
the size of our current window if it
happens to be
less than the current result length
which
initially starts at infinity so this
will definitely execute at least
once if this is true we can update our
result which is stored over here so we
can
set our result to left and right this is
the window
and we can set our result length equal
to the size of this window which we just
computed above but let's compute it
again
this is the size of the window and just
like i showed you in the drawing
while the condition is met we want to
keep shrinking from the left we want to
make this string as
small as it can possibly be so let's
pop from the left of our
window right let's try to minimize it so
i'm going to remove the leftmost
character from our window map so the
leftmost character is
is the string at index left right
and from this i'm going to decrement it
by
1. so now since we removed a character
it's possible that our have and need
condition is no longer met so i'm going
to do something
similar to what we did up here i'm going
to check
if this character s of l was in
count t meaning it's one of the
characters that we need to satisfy our
condition
and if somehow right now for the first
time
that we took this character from our
window and
now the count is actually less than the
count that we
need which is present in count t so now
if it's
if the if by removing a character we
just made it
less than what it needed to be what we
did is we just took our halve
and then decremented it by one right so
this
is just a part of removing a character
from the left we update our map
we update our have count if we need to
and lastly we take our left pointer and
increment it by one because of course we
have to shift this by one
if we're removing a character from the
left of our window
so now after we do this we're going to
potentially check the have and need
condition
and it might be true it might not be
true and whatever it is the
loop is going to execute when it needs
to
so this is all we're doing we're taking
characters adding it to our window map
checking if the condition has been met
updating the window accordingly
that's all we need to do by the end the
result if it exists
will be stored in our result variable so
our result pointer
we can put it in uh left and right we
can take
result and extract it into left and
right these these pointers in this case
these new left and rights will tell us
the result so what we can do is
say return from string s going from
pointer left all the way to pointer
right but we need to add one
for the off by one error and we're only
gonna do this
if the result length has
not has been changed meaning it's no
longer infinity because we know
it's actually possible that a result
does not even exist
if that's not true if a result doesn't
exist we know we have to return
an empty string so there it is this is
the entire code i'll probably have to
link this in the description because
it's pretty long and even kind of messy
and you can see it is definitely very
efficient this is a linear
time algorithm so i really hope that
this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel
a lot and hopefully i'll see you pretty
soon